Ich hoffe, die Tagesschau macht dieses Jahr wieder Jugendwort des Jahres, weil war das
nicht schon?
Das ist doch schon ge...
Was ist denn?
Was ist das denn geworden?
Es ist nicht Bosscock geworden, auch wenn das mein persönliches Lieblingswort gewesen
wäre.
Smash!
Alles klar, Leute, heute wird's ernst.
Heute wird's ernst.
Hallo.
Oh, Kamera laggt.
Was ist das hier?
Da?
Ne, jetzt laggt sie nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Da bisschen weihnachtliche Musik angemacht.
Heute packen wir mal einen neuen Rechner aus.
5000 Euro kostet das Shit, man.
Ich darf's mir gar nicht so oft vorstellen, warum hast du so viel Kohle ausgegeben?
Aber, es musste einfach mal wieder sein.
Mein aktueller Rechner ist 5000 Jahre, Alter.
5 Jahre alt.
Ich kann deinen Teil auch auspacken, Gatschi-Buzz, nice.
Wieso haben die irgendwie so ein komisches Gewinnspiel, oder was?
Nö.
Also, leistungstechnisch, wenn du's brauchst, ja, preislich, nein, auf keinen Fall.
Es lohnt sich eigentlich gar nix aktuell, also, lohnen ist das falsche Wort, ja.
Lohnen ist da prinzipiell das falsche Wort aktuell.
So, ich muss mal gucken, wie ich das jetzt hier am besten mache, weil ich muss ja meine
Bitte-nicht-liegen-Maske anziehen, weil ich werd mich garantiert wieder 30 Milliardenfach
spiegeln.
Wobei, mal gucken, mal gucken, wie spiegelig das überhaupt ist.
Mal abwarten, mal abwarten, wie spiegelig, das ist ja gar nicht so spiegelig.
Also, ich hab schon, wie ihr seht, ich hab hier schon aufgeräumt, wir machen das gleich
fullscreen, ja.
Ich hab hier schon aufgeräumt, also hier, Finger, exzellent, Finger, und Chat.
Wer nicht Primes abt, Primers, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, MonkaW, MonkaW, MonkaW, MonkaW,
MonkaW.
Wait a minute, warum ist es so leise?
Das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht leise.
Und noch was anderes, Merry Christmas!
Ja, exzellent.
Ansonsten mach ich die Overwatch-Wintermusik an, die ist auch gut.
Ah.
Weiß nicht.
Ich brauch die passende Musikstimmung zum Auspacken.
Sonst wird das nix.
Flamongo, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Ich hoffe, du hast dich nicht getränkt gefühlt, Prime zu subscriben.
Ja, also, ich hab schon mal mein Bosch Professional Teppichmesser bereit gelegt,
und das brauchen wir gleich zum Auspacken.
Darkseid, deine Mess...
Die Message von Darkseid wurde geblockt.
Moment, das muss ich euch mal zeigen, wie das bei mir im Chat aussieht.
Schaut mal.
Message von Darkseid gerade.
Ich stell dich ab.
Automod, wegen Aggression hat der Automod gut gemacht.
Der Automod kann ja nicht wissen, um was es geht eigentlich.
Automod, Modge.
Leute, vorhin kam über Discord ein neues Job-Angebot rein.
Ich kann mich aktuell echt nicht mehr retten davor.
Dabei hab ich eigentlich schon unterschrieben, mehr oder weniger.
Ich hatte jetzt die letzten Tage drei neue per Mail, eins per Discord,
noch mal Ex-Kollege, der sich gemeldet hat,
und die anderen, bei denen ich eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger unterschrieben hab.
What the hell, was ist da los?
Ah, oh, das kann ich nicht richtig aussprechen.
Kolukki, dankeschön, 97, 97.
Pog.
Über Discord ist schon 2022?
Ja, na ja.
Warum nicht, ne?
Ich zeig euch mal was, Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Poggers, Poggers.
Ich zeig euch mal kurz was.
Guckt mal, was ich...
Guckt mal, was ich ausgedruckt habe.
Also nicht mit meinem Planet-Drucker, sondern was ich bestellt habe.
Es gibt jetzt die offizielle Max-FPS-Wobblos-Maske.
Zinnig nice.
Die hab ich mir extra anfertigen lassen dafür,
wenn ich mich mal streame, damit ich mich nicht leake.
Das ist die Anti-Leak-Protection.
Wo du die bestellen kannst, gar nicht.
Ich hab die einzigen zwei existierenden Exemplare.
Aber wenn ihr so was für eine gute Idee haltet,
könnt ich wahrscheinlich einfach mal 100 Stück irgendwie anfragen.
Die wird dann sogar gesigned auf der Rückseite, wenn ihr wollt.
Oder auf der Packung.
Nee, ich muss das Business-HRQ-mäßig machen.
Maske, 5 Euro.
Signierte Maske, 15 Euro oder irgendwie was.
Also, das ist, dass ich mich nicht selber leake,
wenn ich mal irgendwie Facecam streame oder so.
Was durchaus beim Rechnerzusammenbauen sein kann.
Übrigens, sag mal, ruckelt das?
Hat mein iPhone Probleme gerade so mit...
Was ist da los?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Nö, okay, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, wir werden den Rechner heute nicht zusammenbauen,
weil es ist noch nicht alles da.
Es fehlt nämlich noch der Kontakt-Frame.
Und haltet euch fest, das Gehäuse.
Die Gehäuse, Leute, sind wieder viel zu langsam gewesen.
Aber wir gucken uns heute die Teile an,
weil ich bin richtig aufgeregt drauf, mir die ganzen Kram anzugucken.
Der Mainframe, genau.
Stell einfach auf den Boden.
Ich mein, wir könnten es theoretisch,
wenn ihr wollt, am Ende mal einschalten.
Könnten wir machen.
Also, wahrscheinlich könnten wir das alles hier so hinlegen.
Und dann einschalten.
Ja, das müsste funktionieren.
Es wird echt mal Zeit, dass ich mir eine ordentliche Kamera kauf.
Mein iPhone-Kamera ist schön und gut, aber hier, das sackt.
Vor allem hatte ich auch voll die Fokusprobleme, wenn man so macht.
Guck mal hier.
Voll am Rumpacken.
So, Leute, ich warte jetzt noch eine Minute,
dann ist der Stream zehn Minuten on.
Und dann fangen wir an.
Ich bin äußerst, wie würden sie jetzt sagen,
auf irgendeiner Präsentation?
We are super excited to share.
Oder irgendwie sowas erzählen sie doch immer.
Super excited, hyped and thrilled to share the news.
A new Mass Effect game is coming.
Major changes, 16 times the size.
World premiere.
Nächste Einkauf.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich lasse mal die Maske hier liegen, die schadet ja nicht.
So, also wir fangen von oben nach unten an.
Ganz einfach.
Wer sich interessiert dafür, was ich hier eigentlich auspacke,
der kann im Chat einfach jetzt mal Ausrufezeichen PC machen.
Wir haben das nämlich schon aktualisiert.
Und hier sieht man die Teile Liste.
Ich zeige es jetzt aber nicht im Stream direkt,
weil vielleicht will der eine oder andere irgendwie sich überraschen,
was alles kommt.
Aber ich kann euch sagen, es ist un...
Tja, unendlich das Falschwort.
Unvernünftig, unvernünftig teuer.
Hatte der Bauer nicht auch mal so ein Projekt, unvernünftig Server?
Sowas in der Richtung ist, was jetzt für mich plus für meinen neuen Gaming PC.
Ja, Ausrufezeichen PC, das geht nur einmal die Minute.
Ihr könnt den Link von oben.
Doch, das geht.
Guck doch zwei Nachrichten oben drüber.
Na, du kannst es nicht.
Es können jetzt nicht 80 Leute spammen.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall teuer.
Beziehungsweise, was heißt das?
Es wird teuer.
Es ist teuer, weil selbstverständlich habe ich alles schon bezahlt.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bestelle nichts auf Raten oder sowas.
Im neuen Gaming PC schon mal gar nicht.
Quasi neuer Mainframe, den ich hier zusammenbaue.
Ja.
So, wir fangen an.
Auf geht's.
So.
Mit was fangen wir dann an?
Wir fangen...
Okay, hier.
Easy.
Wir fangen mit was ganz Simples an.
Da gibt es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel zu sagen.
Wir fangen mit der SSD an.
Massive SSD.
Ist eine...
Ah, die haben schon...
Leute, die iPhone-Kamera ruckelt, wenn sie fokussiert.
Das ist total...
Total für'n Arsch.
Leute, hier ruckelt es nicht.
Aber sobald die iPhone-Kamera fokussiert ruckelt es.
Naja, gut.
Also.
SSD.
Gibt's nicht viel zu sagen.
Sie haben ein bisschen versäumt.
Blazingly fast zu schreiben.
Erwähnst du den neuen PC bei der Steuererklärung als Arbeitsmittel?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Selbstverständlich, Leute.
Selbstverständlich.
Blazingly fast, written in Rust.
Machen wir mal auf.
Gibt's nicht sonderlich viel zu sehen, aber...
Wir...
Wir machen es trotzdem auf.
Leute, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Als nächstes packen wir das Mainboard aus.
Gucken da rein und machen die SSD schon mal auf das Mainboard drauf.
Weil...
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das mit der Halterung funktioniert.
Ich hab gesehen...
In dem Video, dass man die nicht mehr schrauben muss.
Sondern jetzt nur noch festklippst.
Ja, das Mainboard hat auch einen Heatsink.
Können wir uns gleich angucken.
Ich pack das jetzt mal aus.
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Also hier.
Plistering...
Plistering Speed.
Endless Victory.
Scheuer der Satz für eine SSD, oder?
Dann kurz...
Plistering Speed, Endless Victory.
Packen wir mal aus.
Gibt's da irgendwie irgendwas, was man hier aufmachen muss?
Ähm, ja, hier neben.
Hier muss man aufmachen, guck.
Ich sollte das vielleicht mal ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen weniger ausmachen.
So.
Excellent.
Riesenverpackung für noch kleineres Ding.
2TB.
PCI Express 4 SSD.
Könnt ihr den QR-Code scannen?
Keine Ahnung, was dann da rauskommt.
Und im Endeffekt...
Es ist halt eine SSD.
Was soll ich da groß dazu sagen?
Wir können noch mal kurz schauen,
ob da irgendwie was unten drunter ist.
Okay, Samsung...
China...
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Wobei man sagen muss,
dass es Samsung ist wahrscheinlich,
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht China-Chinesen-Zeug,
sondern Koreanisch.
Nee, Moment, Samsung.
Warte mal.
Nicht Sony.
Doch, Samsung, Koreanisch.
Sony, äh, Japanisch.
Ja, genau.
So.
Also, SSD.
Ich pfeffer alles mal,
was ich hier an Verpackung habe.
Pfeffer ich einfach mal hier.
Zur Seite.
Erstes Teil, SSD.
Mehr gibt's dazu, glaube ich, nicht zu sagen.
Es ist halt eine SSD.
Eine M2-SSD.
Wie man sie kennt.
Ja.
Wird heiß as fuck.
Und...
ist schnell.
Und ist zwei Terabyte groß.
Okay.
Als Festplatte habe ich nur eine 14 Terabyte Magnet.
Also, klassische Disk-Festplatte.
In 14 Terabyte.
Die habe ich mir nicht gekauft.
Die habe ich aber im Bild
auf Geiz, glaube ich, dabei geschrieben.
Weil, die kommt halt in den Rechner rein.
Die habe ich dabei geschrieben,
aber die hatte ich noch.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wo...
Wo habe ich die denn?
Moment, ich hole die mal.
Dass wir alles zusammen haben.
Die ist nicht blazingly fast.
Aber...
Die ist blazingly groß.
Das ist auch was für...
Ich glaube, diese Skyhawk-Series ist, glaube ich...
Könnte sogar eins sein mit so Überlagerungen oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Für meine Zwecke.
Für Downloads drauf speichern.
Und ab und zu ein paar Videos drauf zwischenspeichern und sowas.
Oder auch als Render-Output für die Videos.
Ist das vollkommen ausreichend.
So, also.
Festplatte.
SSD.
Pog.
Next.
Ach so, ich habe gesagt, wir machen das Mainboard als nächstes.
Also, Mainboard stellt.
Gucken wir, dass da irgendwie doch mein Name drauf steht.
Und Adresse und so.
Sollte eigentlich nicht.
Sollte auf Karton außen drauf stehen.
Man weiß es ja nie.
Okay, Mainboard.
Es haben viele Leute schon auf Ebay geschrieben.
Auf Ebay?
Leute, ich habe echt Probleme in letzter Zeit.
Ich rede schneller als ich denke im Kopf.
Und da kommt dann so blöde Sätze bei raus.
Auf Twitter.
Es haben Leute auf Twitter schon geschrieben.
1 Gigabyte.
Mainboard.
Mal gucken.
Ich wollte nicht 700 Euro für eine Mainboard ausgeben.
Adresse liegt.
Ja, hier, guck, eindeutig.
Da sieht man es.
Guck hier, hier.
Elite IX.
Da wohne ich.
Das Problem ist, dass ich älter werde.
Ja, das kann auch sein.
Wenn das nächste taucht, ganz einfach.
Dann kaufe ich ein anderes Board und schicke das zurück.
Easy.
So, ich würde sagen, wir packen das mal aus und gucken uns, wie man dann die SSD drauf
macht.
Sekunde.
Weil ich muss mal kurz schauen, ob das irgendwie fest ist hier.
Zack.
Nee.
Oh nee.
Leak Time.
Leak Time, Leute.
Das spiegelt erst.
Fuck.
Moment.
Ich muss meine Anti-Leak-Protection aufziehen.
Ach, das muss man um die Ohren machen.
Anti-Leak-Protection ist am Start.
Hör ich mich ein bisschen dumm voran jetzt?
Anti-Leak-Protection.
Okay.
Easy.
Gar nicht?
Na ja.
So, also, da haben wir es.
Spiegele ich mich da überhaupt drin?
Nee, ja.
Spiegelt man sich doch gar nicht.
Na gut.
So, packen wir das mal aus.
Der verzehrt.
Ich glaube, ich spiegele mich eh nicht.
Aber wenn wir das ausgepackt haben, kann ich die Maske wieder abziehen.
Exzellent.
Und das alles nur...
Das ist aber sehr minimalistisch, was da drin ist, oder?
Sehr minimalistisch.
Hält sich wirklich sehr in Grenzen, was da drin ist.
Ich meine, es ist immerhin ein 340-Euro-Mainboard.
Also hätte man ja vielleicht noch das eine oder andere Stromkabel oder sowas erwarten
können, aber No-Pass gibt es nicht.
Ein SATA-Kabel.
Es gibt im Endeffekt...
Ach, komm, Leute.
Ich spiegele mich nicht.
Scheiße.
Ich ziehe die Maske, ich ziehe das jetzt wieder ab.
So, also.
Jetzt haben wir hier einen SATA-Kabel, das ist aber nett für 340 Euro, einen SATA-Kabel,
GGEATS.
Und der Rest ist im Endeffekt...
Im Endeffekt ist es das...
Was ist das?
Ist das fürs Gehäuse?
Front-Panel?
Okay.
Ich pfeffer das Ding auch mal wieder in die Ecke.
Machen wir mal auf.
Fertig.
Back.
Dann das mit der Hand auf.
Ja, kriegt man von Hand auf.
Okay, holen wir das Ding mal raus.
Und gucken uns das mal an.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein fettes Board von der Größe her.
Also da ist nichts mit Mikro ATX oder sowas.
Also das ist schon...
Das ist schon ein bisschen größer.
So, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal von unten an.
Nichts spannendes.
Außer halt diese Mounting-Platte, die wir wahrscheinlich dann austauschen müssen.
Wenn man den Frame dran macht und die Wasserkühlung.
So, nichts spannendes. Anschlüsse.
Anschlüsse haben wir.
2,5 Gigabit Ethernet.
Also 2,5 Gigabit Netzwerk.
Riecher Audio-Ausgang, das ist mir relativ wichtig.
Weil ich das eh an mein Audio-Interface anschließe.
Äh, gut, Mikrophone-Lineout brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Werde ich eh nicht anschließen, ich schließe das eh alles da an.
Dann haben wir relativ...
Naja, großzügig kann man jetzt in der heutigen Zeit ja nicht sagen.
Gibt ja welche, die sind quasi vollgepflastert mit USB.
Wir haben jede Menge USB. Wir haben USB 3.2.
USB 3.2 Displayport HDMI.
Für die CPU, also für die GPU, die in der CPU drin ist.
Dann haben wir USB 3.2.
Oh nee, USB-Standards verfolgen mich wieder.
Ich vermute mal, das hier ist USB 3.2 Gen 1 und das ist USB 3.2 Gen 2.
Wobei es ja eigentlich auch nicht mehr Gen 1 und 2 heißt.
Sondern USB 4 Gen 2 x 1 oder so.
Wir lassen es, wir lassen es bleiben.
Also ich glaube, das hier ist echtes USB 3.2.
So wie es damals rausgekommen ist.
Und das hier ist USB 3.1.
Was die retroaktiv umbenannt haben.
Das dürften recht Neues sein.
Das ist auf jeden Fall denke ich, nee, das ist noch kein USB 4.
Das ist ein USB 3.2 Gen 2 x 2 oder sowas.
So und das da hinten ist halt die Frage.
Entweder sind das klassische USB 2.
Oder sind auch 3.1, 3.2, keine Ahnung.
So, hier haben wir Bluetooth und Wi-Fi Antenne.
Wohlgemerkt Wi-Fi 6, nicht Wi-Fi 6e.
Ist mir aber egal, ich habe noch nicht meinen Wi-Fi 6 Router.
Ähm, im Schwachsinn.
Access Point.
So schaut es aus, recht übersichtlich.
Was haben wir auf dem Mainboard schönes drauf?
Wir haben einen Slot für die M2.
Da, da waren wir gleich rein.
Wir haben einen Slot für die M2 SSD.
Schauen wir mal.
Ah nee, guck mal, man braucht trotzdem, man braucht doch noch eine Schraube.
Muss ich gleich, gleich mal aufmachen.
Ah nee, reicht nicht.
Hab ich überhaupt einen hier gerade, mit dem das geht?
Nee, da muss ich...
What the fuck?
Hab ich da irgendwas drinne?
So, das sind ja so super kleine Schräubchen.
Sieht nicht so aus.
Muss ich gerade mal einen holen, dass ich das aufschrauben kann.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist Mini.
Schauen wir mal kurz ein.
Für den Fall der Felle, ich hab mal zwei Stück mitgebracht.
Der hier müsste aber, müsste aber eigentlich gehen.
Ja.
Hä?
Okay, man soll das, soll man das nicht drehen?
Weil...
Ah doch, man braucht einfach ein bisschen Kraft, dann ist okay, dann geht das.
So, dann machen wir das mal kurz raus, gucken uns das mal an.
Okay, hier kommt die SSD drauf.
Anscheinend muss man das Ganze doch schrauben.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich hab gesehen, man muss nicht mehr schrauben, sondern das Ganze geht.
Guck mal, hier ist der Clips-Mechanismus.
Ah, das hier, okay, okay, ich hab's verstanden.
Hiermit, mit diesem Clips, seht ihr das?
Mit diesem Clips, den man so drehen kann.
Damit, damit macht man die M2, damit macht man die SSD fest.
Und die Schraube ist halt einfach für den Heatsink, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Das hier müssen wir abziehen, das sind Wärmepads.
Okay, gut, machen wir gleich, weil wir uns den Rest angeguckt haben.
Ganz klassisch, wie seit 85 Jahren, eine BIOS-Batterie.
Ähm, was haben wir sonst noch?
Ja, wir haben den CPU-Sockel, vier RAM-Bänke, wohlgemerkt, wo, welcher RAM-Slot ist.
Wie sind die?
Wahrscheinlich ist das 1,2 und das 3,4, oder?
So Dual-Channel-mäßig.
Steht das da, seht ihr da irgendwas?
Nee, ich seh da nichts.
Der erste M2-Slot, der klaut an der Grafikkarte die Lanes.
Nee.
War das nicht so?
Der erste PCI-Express-Slot ist der, der direkt an die CPU geht?
Das hat mit der Grafikkarte nichts zu tun.
Inzwischen CPU und RAM steht was?
Ach, hier.
Genau.
Ach nee, guck mal, A1, A2.
Ja, jetzt ist halt die Frage, bestückt man A1 und B1 oder bestückt man A1 und A2?
Das müsste man mal nachgucken, das weiß ich nicht.
So, dann haben wir jede Menge CPU.
Spannungsversorgung, Kühler.
Und hier ist halt nochmal ein Kühler drauf und die ganzen Sachen hinten.
Gibt's jetzt nicht so viel zu sehen?
Ach ja, hier neben, so Chap.
Warum das bei diesem riesen fetten Port Chap sein muss, weiß ich nicht.
SATA, für die Falle der Fälle, dass man es braucht.
Haben wir auch ein bisschen USB extra.
ATX-Anschluss für das Netzteil.
Hier hinten haben wir noch zwei 8-Pin-Stecker auch fürs Netzteil.
Bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, ob man da alle anschließen muss mittlerweile.
So, dann haben wir einen verstärkten PCI Express 16.
Einfach alle bestücken, ich hab bloß zwei Riegel.
Und zeigt mal, wie ist der Mechanismus?
Okay.
Kommt das nicht ein bisschen mit der SSD?
In die Quere?
Nö.
Ah, das haben sie gut ausgemessen.
Guck mal, das kommt nicht mit der SSD in die Quere.
Es ist genau, genau passend zur SSD.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, was gibt's sonst?
Wir können mal hier drunter gucken.
Ich vermute aber mal, hier sind noch weitere M2-Anschlüsse.
Und sonst nix.
Wir gucken aber mal drunter, immer nicht, dass es was schaden würde.
Na, auf.
Oder ist es schon auf?
Jetzt.
Hier muss man auch.
Das sind die M2, die du benutzen sollst, bist du dir da sicher?
Das ist aber wirklich...
Seid ihr euch da sicher, Chat?
Oder seid ihr nur am Chatten?
Ah, das ist noch nicht auf.
Weil...
Nur diese M2 hat einen Pad obendrauf.
Was für mich heißt...
Da sollen die SSDs, da sollen die SSD rein.
Wir gucken uns gleich das Handbuch an, habt ihr recht.
So, also wir haben hier unten drunter noch mal...
M2M, M2Q, M2P, okay, was auch immer.
Da müssen wir doch mal ins Handbuch reingucken.
Wir haben zumindest noch mal 2, 3 M2-SSD
oder M2-Anschlüsse, man muss ja nicht zwangsläufig eine SSD reinmachen.
Also die hier sind auf jeden Fall PCI-Express.
Ich vermute, dass die hier auch PCI-Express sind.
Allerdings wahrscheinlich irgendwie hier über den Chipsatz gehen.
Und der hier direkt zur CPU.
Das ist meine Vermutung jetzt.
Wir fahren einen Blick in das Handbuch, ja, machen wir jetzt.
Elite DDR4, nee, DDR5.
Die Musik ist viel zu laut, man.
Nicht übertreiben.
So, was sagt denn?
Hier, also was haben wir denn hier für Anschlüsse?
Hier, M2CPU.
Das ist wahrscheinlich den, den man für die Systemplatte verwenden will.
Ja, Leute, genau.
Und da klaut meiner Grafik, siehst du mal,
der Chat ist wieder richtig krass an dem, was er am besten machen kann, chatten.
Und nicht wissen, was er schreibt.
Also da sieht man es doch.
Man sieht, dass die obere SSD, also die, die da,
geht direkt an die CPU und hat nichts mit der Grafikkarte zu tun.
Und die unteren, richtig, richtig Chatting, ja.
So, und die unteren, die sind angebunden über den Chipsat.
Das heißt, theoretisch möchte man die obere SSD,
also die hier wahrscheinlich benutzen für das System letztendlich unterm Strich.
Ganz ehrlich, wird es wahrscheinlich gar keinen großen Unterschied machen.
Gut, also, next.
Hast du wirklich bekommen, man kann mittlerweile Mario 64 auf Android kompilen?
Nee, habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Aber wundert mich nicht, ich meine, die haben das ja reverse-ingeniert.
Da gibt es ja mittlerweile sogar Multiplayer-Mods und sowas, richtig geil.
Also, wie sagt man, was Nintendo halt nicht macht,
aber deswegen sind Mods halt auch geil.
Eines der blöden Sachen an Diablo 2 Resurrected ist ja,
dass die jeglichen Mod-Support auch abgeschafft haben.
Also, nicht nur, dass sie es verboten haben, nein,
sie haben auch die Connection-Möglichkeit ausgebaut,
um dich eben zu modded Servern zu verbinden,
was halt einfach so ziemlich alle Mods gefickt hat, ja.
So, ja, mehr gibt es auf Mainboard eigentlich jetzt wirklich nicht zu sehen.
Anschlüsse, Anschlüsse, M2.
Also nur von der Idee, theoretisch müsste man das Ding ja dann...
Oh, chat, soll ich mein Anti-Static-Armband...
Ach komm, scheiß drauf.
Anti-Static-Armband an.
Ich könnte mal ein Anti-Static-Armband anziehen.
Ich habe ein Anti-Static-Armband.
Aber ich habe schon eine Anti-Static-Auflage, das muss reichen.
Ich mache das wie Verge, ich mache das wireless, Leute.
Ich hänge es mir einfach an den Arm und dann ist es gut.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt.
Nee, warte mal.
Muss man das hier abmachen?
Okay, das ist die Unterseite von der S...
Das ist quasi das Wärmeleitpad von unten.
Was im Endeffekt heißt, wie kommt die SSD dann da rein?
So?
Nee, oder?
Doch, so.
Und jetzt Clips.
Ach, easy.
Das ist ja gut gemacht.
Guck mal.
Jetzt ist das hier eingerastet direkt automatisch.
Jetzt ist die fest, ohne zu schrauben.
Jetzt ist die fest.
Nein, ich muss ja noch die... und unten die Pads abmachen und so was.
Und jetzt kann man hier einfach drücken und dann geht es automatisch wieder raus.
Das ist eine coole... Das finde ich gut.
Das ist eine nice Idee.
Guckt hier jetzt, Leute.
Zack, ist drin.
Und hier, flupp, ist wieder raus.
Poggers, Alter.
Sagt ihr mal, die SSD muss ja mit diesem Gedöns da oben drauf hin.
Wollte man das abmachen, bevor man da den Heatsink drauf macht, dieses Gedöns, oder macht es keinen Unterschied?
Da habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Nicht abmachen.
Dann mache ich es nicht ab.
Okay, das bauen wir dann später ein, falls wir heute noch dazu kommen, das einzuschalten.
Gut, hier unten kommt aktuell nichts rein.
Das reicht mir erstmal.
2TB SSD, 14TB Magnetfestplatte.
Und dann kommt ja noch eine 2TB externe SSD vom alten PC dran.
Ist jetzt Storage technisch erstmal genug für mich?
Die Folie muss ab, das ist mir schon klar.
Gut, dann machen wir das mal wieder zu.
Also hier unten haben wir im Prinzip 3x noch die Möglichkeit, etwas anzuschließen.
Ich werde das mal nur leicht festmachen.
Weil ich will es ja nachher wieder abkriegen.
Weil eigentlich brauche ich es nicht nachher.
Will ich wieder gar nichts dran machen.
So, jetzt haben wir das fest.
Gut, Mainboard.
Ich mache es jetzt mal wieder weg, weil wir müssen noch etwas anderes ausmachen.
Achso, was haben wir denn noch dabei?
Zeig mal her.
Absolut High-End SATA-Kabel.
Pfeffer ich gleich mal hier in die Ecke.
Und wir haben noch, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung was das ist.
Wi-Fi-Antennen wahrscheinlich.
Wi-Fi-Antennen?
Ich denke mal Wi-Fi-Antennen müssten es sein.
Hätten die nicht einfach eine stinknormale Antenne nehmen können?
Anstatt so ein komisches Ding hier?
Also sprich, Leute ich mache da einfach ganz normale Antennen dran.
Ich habe genug.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal ob das überhaupt die Wi-Fi-Antenne ist.
Komm mal her, ja sieht so aus.
Bluetooth-Wi-Fi in einem.
Naja, also ganz im Ernst.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht dran machen.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich eine ganz normale Antenne.
Wie gesagt, ich habe genug, ich werde einfach eine ganz normale Antenne dran machen und fertig.
Warum nicht LAN?
Äh, mache ich doch.
Das wird nur über Kabel betrieben.
Aber für Bluetooth ist es ganz praktisch.
Mit dem Ding ist, nein, nein, nein, mit dem hier, hier mit ist Endless Victory.
Das Mainboard ist nicht Endless Victory.
Die SSD ist Endless Victory.
Gut, ja.
Also ganz ehrlich, macht jetzt nicht den geilsten, nein auch dieses komische.
Das sieht fast aus als kannst du damit irgendwie so dein Frühstück schneiden oder so.
Naja, gut.
Schmeißen wir das auch mal in die Ecke.
Die hier mache ich erstmal temporär wieder drauf.
Hüpse.
Die mache ich erstmal temporär wieder drauf, damit ich das Mainboard jetzt in die Ecke legen kann.
Das werde ich jetzt nicht so in die Ecke feuern wie das andere Zeug.
Das lege ich jetzt erstmal vorsichtig.
Wieder.
Moment, ich hätte es halt ausziehen.
Vorsichtig hier wieder hin.
Okay, next.
Was, was machen wir?
RAM, RAM.
Ja, bevor wir CPU und Grafikkarte machen, RAM.
RAM.
Wie das die coolen Leute sagen.
Haben wir G-Skill, Trident Z5 und ganz wichtig Leute hier, ganz wichtig.
Für mehr FPS, Performance Boost.
Also, also, ich meine das liegt nicht XMP oder sowas.
Das braucht keine RGB.
RGB, das allerwichtigste.
Soll ich, ich könnte mal so eine RGB Lampe hier anmachen jetzt dafür.
Aber ich habe kein Netzteil.
Nein Leute, RGB Beleuchtung.
Passend, ich muss passende Stimmung für den RAM machen.
Moment, Moment.
Jetzt noch kurz Licht aus.
Moment, Moment, das muss jetzt sein.
Oh.
So, Mist, man erkennt das gar nicht richtig.
Man sieht die RGB Geschichte gar nicht richtig jetzt.
Na, das ist ja doof.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen sieht man es jetzt.
Jetzt ist der Stream doppelt schnell, ja.
Zweimal 48 FPS.
Also das ist meine, meine Fenster Beleuchtung, die ich hier gerade an habe.
So, also einmal, einmal RGB für den RGB RAM.
Und jetzt mache ich aber wieder Licht an, weil man sieht man nichts.
Zeig mal, was können wir, was haben wir denn hier?
DDR5, gut, ich mache Licht wieder an.
Decke, was los?
Exzellent.
Da sind wir wieder.
Alles klar, so, machen wir es mal auf.
Es ist, by the way, DDR5 6400, 2 x 32 GB.
Für läppische 530 Euro.
100 Gramm.
Okay, haben wir mal auf.
Der RAM.
Und flop in die Ecke damit.
Packen wir mal aus.
Ganz schön fette RAM Riegel, oder?
Welche High IQ Taktik braucht man?
Ah hier, einfach aufmachen.
Easy.
Ein G-Skill Logo.
Für alle, die sich gerne sowas auf den Rechner pappen.
Ich pappe am liebsten gar nichts auf meinen Rechner drauf.
Und da haben wir 2 x RAM Riegel.
Also eigentlich nichts besonderes.
Hier mit G-Skill Echtheits Logo.
Wer auch immer das braucht.
Es geht ums haben vor allem, das ist korrekt.
So, hier oben ist anscheinend die RGB-Geschichte.
Und ansonsten ist es halt...
Ich glaube, so rum muss das rein.
Aber ansonsten ist es halt RAM.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht allzu viel zu sagen.
Im Endeffekt ist es halt RAM.
Oh, RAM.
Ja.
Nun.
Ah ja, da freue ich mich drauf Leute.
Auf das nächste freue ich mich wirklich.
Ich lasse es euch aussuchen.
Was wollen wir als nächstes uns angucken?
CPU, Grafikkarte, Wasserkühlung.
Wasserkühlung, GPU.
Also es ist so ein bisschen...
Okay, eigentlich ist es nämlich 50-50.
Komm, wir machen eine Umfrage.
Eine 1-Minuten-Umfrage.
Für mehr lohnt sich das eigentlich gar nicht.
Hier, kommen wir mal her.
Voll.
Was als nächstes?
Fragezeichen.
GPU, CPU, Wasserkühlung, CPU, GPU.
Zusätzliche Abstimmung zulasten mit Kekse.
Ja, genau.
Umfrage.
Okay, Wasserkühlung ist am uninteressantsten.
Es gibt Grafikkarte.
Okay, Grafikkarte.
Grafikkarte hat gewonnen.
Alles klar.
Wir machen Grafikkarte, danach CPU und zum Schluss Wasserkühlung.
Es wurde leicht gefaked bei der Umfrage.
Okay, letztendlich ist es auch egal.
Ich muss ab und zu mal ein paar Umfragen machen,
dass die Leute ihre Channel Points loswerden können.
Weil bei mir kannst du sonst mit Channel Points ja nichts machen.
Oh, oh, das ist Slippery, die Verpackung.
So, steht da irgendwie mein Name drauf?
Nope, no pass, nix, alles gut.
Auf geht's.
Hier.
Ach so, Moment, Leute.
Ich muss erst mal wieder...
Hier.
Bäm.
Ist so groß, passt gar nicht in die Kamera rein.
Sekunde.
Ich muss mal Platz machen.
Das muss mal kurz alles weg.
Muss mal kurz sich auf die Fensterbank verziehen.
Also, das Ding ist wirklich fett.
Sowohl vom Preis her als auch von der Verpackung her.
Von der Performance her müsste sie auch fett sein.
So, das Ding.
Zack.
Das ist eine GeForce RTX 4090.
Und zwar, um genau zu sein, eine Zotac.
Hat keinen tieferen Sinn, dass es eine Zotac geworden ist.
Der einzige Grund, warum es die geworden ist...
Ach so, um...
Das hier ist es.
Fuck, Alter, das passt hier gar nicht rein.
Guck mal.
Ein Trinity OC.
Letztendlich ist es der einzige Grund, warum ich das Ding gekauft habe.
Weil die gut lieferbar war.
Und jetzt nicht übertrieben viel mehr gekostet hat, wie lieferbar sein.
Die übertakken, nee.
Ganz ehrlich, da steht zwar OC.
Aber ganz im Ernst, wisst ihr, wie hoch das OC ist?
15 Megahertz.
Das ist nix.
Who cares?
Das kann jeder selbst machen.
Das schafft jeder andere auch.
Also, das juckt jetzt nicht.
So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz Off-Kamera aufmachen.
Weil das passt hier nicht alles auf den Tisch drauf.
So, ich hab offen.
Ich meine, die Verpackung macht was her.
Aber das würde ich auch erwarten bei so einem teuren Teil.
Na, komm raus.
Zack.
Noch mehr Verpackung.
Love Game.
Was wollt ihr?
Love Gaming.
Power the Win.
Ja, Power braucht das Ding.
Du brauchst quasi...
Du musst neuen Stromabschlag bezahlen für das Teil.
Was ist denn das?
Ist das eine Maske?
Ist das eine Zotac-Maske?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Also, es ist keine CD.
Aber was die Maus im Bild macht.
Oh, komm mal.
Die sind schon mal nicht gut drauf hier.
Das ist negative Amazon.
Ach nee, easy.
Leute, das ist ein Handbuch und so was Unsinniges.
Braucht auch keiner.
Handbuch.
Kackel.
Mensch.
Bam.
In die Ecke damit.
So.
Ich hab keinen Platz für das...
Moment.
Leute.
Kein Platz für...
Für das Raumschiff.
So, weg damit.
So.
Hier.
Da ist der Übeltäter, Leute.
Da ist der Übeltäter.
Das ist der, der brennt manchmal.
Das da, das da.
Das ist ein fettes Ding, man.
Ich komm hier kaum durch, man.
So.
Okay, wir nähern uns.
Wir nähern uns.
Boah, ist das ein Riesenteil, Alter.
Meine gute Gatschi-Buzz.
Hyper Gatschi ist das ja schon richtig.
Da muss der ganz schön was reinfahren hier.
Boah.
Alter, was ein Teil.
Da fuck, man.
Ist das groß.
Leute, das ist ein Ries...
Das Ding ist riesig.
Guck mal, ich halt mal meinen Arm daneben.
Guck mal.
Das ist meine Hand.
Passt mal auf.
Das geht mir...
Quasi...
Hier, guck mal.
Das geht mir bis zum...
Bis zum Ellenbogen hier.
Das Mainboard...
Ähm, das geht nicht.
Das ist grad unter den anderen Kisten drunter.
Also das ist wirklich ein Riesending.
Wir können mal...
Just for fun, guck mal.
Das ist der Ram.
Im Vergleich.
Passt das Ding drauf?
Klar, selbstverständlich passt das drauf.
Der Ram passt da quasi dreimal fast rein.
Also das Ding ist richtig fett.
Guck mal, ihr habt doch vorhin die Maske gesehen.
Die Maske ist quasi zur Hälfte.
Die gehen aber einen Kühler halbwegs.
Das war's.
Ich kann es euch leider nicht in Fußballfelder umrechnen.
Auch wenn das ja so üblich ist in Deutschland.
Okay, riesig fette Grafikkarte.
Was haben wir im Endeffekt?
PC-Express-Anschluss.
Was sonst?
Klar, den muss ich nicht zeigen.
PC-Express-Anschluss.
Hier oben ist der Übeltäter.
Gucken euch an.
Hier ist der neue Anschluss.
Oh, da ist eine Warnung.
Moment, da ist eine Warnung drauf.
Lasst mal kurz gucken.
Power consumption.
Okay.
Please only...
Ich lese euch das mal vor, das kann man nämlich schlecht lesen.
Please only use separate power cables for each power connection.
Use 12-Volt-H-PWR-Connection, if your PSU natively supports it.
Mein Netzteil supportet das nicht natively.
Aber...
Ist das hier?
Was ist denn das?
Warum guckt denn das hier raus unten?
Hat das einen Sinn?
Sind das Spannungswandler oder so?
Oder ist das der...
Nee, das ist die Unterseite von dem Grafik-Ding, dass man eine Wasserkühlung dran machen kann
oder so, gell?
Oder was für was ist das?
Ah, das ist, dass ich hier eine Wasserkühlung dran machen könnte.
Verstehe.
Okay.
Ja, also hier ist der Power-Connector.
Also im Prinzip muss man...
Moment, ich mach das mal kurz auf.
Man muss...
Das ist ja auch geil, Alter.
Ach ja, ich hab übrigens vor, mir den Be Quiet-Grafikkartenadapter zu kaufen, dass ich das direkt vom Netzteil anschließen
kann.
Geht aktuell nicht, weil das keinen Shop lieferbar hat.
Also man muss tatsächlich...
Guckt mal, das hier kommt auf die Netzteilseite.
Du brauchst vier Anschlüsse am Netzteil und das ist die Seite auf der Grafikkarte.
Also ist schon...
Hat was, ja?
Braucht ein bisschen was.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
Wir haben hier ein komisches Zotac-Logo.
Wir haben noch mal für alle die Erinnerung, dass es eine GeForce RTX ist.
Da wären wir so jetzt natürlich auch nicht drauf gekommen.
Wir gucken uns noch mal die Lüfter an.
Muss ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Lüfter.
Lüfter, wahrscheinlich ein bisschen RGB.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Dann haben wir hier noch was.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Irgendwer ein Verleuchtenplan.
Für RGB-Beleuchtung wahrscheinlich, oder?
Das ist bestimmt für RGB-Beleuchtung.
Wegschmeißen.
Bloated.
Und dann haben wir hier noch...
Was ist das?
In den Mounting-Praket oder sowas?
Ist das vielleicht für vertikales Mounten oder sowas?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Warum auch immer man da noch mal so ein Mounting-Ding dabei hat.
Ach so, das ist, weil das sonst quasi am Slot hängt und sonst zu schwer ist.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Da muss man dann drauf achten.
Nicht so einfach.
Slot-Entlastung.
Jo.
Nice.
Hätten wir das?
Pfeffer ich mal die...
Wobei, hey, zu dem Powerkabel bin ich nett.
Weil, man weiß ja nie.
So, hier.
Grafikkade.
Sehr schön.
Tja.
Mehr gibt's da, glaube ich, nicht zu sagen.
Es ist recht unspektakulär.
Ich meine, also die Grafikkade ist sicher spektakulär, weil es so ein fettes Ding ist.
Aber sonst ist es halt eine Grafikkade.
Was will ich da groß zu sagen?
Kostet, soll ich vielleicht auch noch sagen, hat mich, glaube ich, 2250 Euro gekostet.
Hast du noch einen alten Rechner von 2013, ja?
Also ist doch etwas teurer.
Aber...
Was muss, das muss.
Gut.
Die packe ich mal wieder ein.
Die will ich nicht kaputt machen.
Die packe ich mal kurz wieder ein.
Das ist ja mit Abstand das teuerste an dem ganzen Rechner.
Ja.
Muss ich auch mal vorstellen.
Okay.
Dann hätten wir die Grafikkade.
POG-GPU.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
CPU oder Wasserkühlung?
Ich würde sagen, CPU.
Die Leute, die abgestimmt haben, haben, glaube ich, gesagt CPU.
Und da haben wir, wie könnte es nicht anders sein?
Einen...
13900K.
Warum?
Weil es keinen Sinn macht.
Einfach weil ich es haben will.
Für meinen Anwendungsfall, der ja live streaming ist, Video rendern und spielen, wäre ein
i7 nicht...
Achso, und viele VMs laufen lassen.
Wäre ein i7 nicht wirklich irgendwie...
So der Verlust.
Aber...
Die Stromrechnung muss steigen.
Das muss, das muss, genau.
Also sie haben eine ganz schicke Verpackung.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Hier.
So ein...
Naja.
Sie können sich auch mal Mühe geben bei dem Preis.
Ich weiß nicht.
Guckt mal, guckt mal bei mir in die Liste.
Ich weiß gar nicht aus dem Kopf, was die CPU kostet.
Ich glaube 750 Euro.
Der Kram ist unglaublich teuer alles.
Gut.
Jetzt kommt die große Preisfrage.
Wie macht man das auf?
Wahrscheinlich muss man hier durchschneiden.
Aha.
Und dann fällt es quasi auseinander.
Ok, hier haben wir noch irgendwelche Intel Docs, die man nicht braucht.
Sieht aus wie irgendeine Oplade zu Weihnachten.
Was das für eine Unterlage ist.
Das ist eigentlich so eine Anti-Static-Matte, die ich gerne zum Löten und so verwende.
Und basteln.
Da klebt nichts.
Aber die habe ich halt einfach so drunter, weil die liegt hier immer.
Also wenn ihr schon mal andere Streams dabei macht, wo wir was gebastelt haben, die liegt hier eigentlich immer.
Waffeleisen, ja hat ein bisschen was.
Ok, machen wir mal auf.
Da ist er.
Ok, man muss ja sagen, die Verpackung macht auch wieder was her.
Unbedeutendste an sich, ja.
Aber ich meine für den Preis kann man da schon ein bisschen was erwarten.
Da ist er.
Ein Intel Core i9.
13900K.
Mit irgendwelchem komischen ID Zeug unten drunter.
Und diese CPU wird nicht geköpft.
Nicht wie mein letzter.
Den letzten habe ich geköpft.
Werde ich nicht mal machen.
Ist auch nicht mal notwendig.
Die Dinger haben ja ordentlich verlötete Heatspreader, hoffe ich mal zumindest.
Und der 8700K, der hatte ja noch so eine komische Geschichte mit Wärmeleitpaste zwischen Heatspreader und CPU.
Also Heatspreader ist das Ding, was ihr hier oben seht.
Das ist der Heatspreader.
Also unten drunter ist halt die CPU, also die Oberseite von der CPU.
Das ist der Heatspreader, dass eben der Lüfter mehr Fläche hat.
Dass die Heats sich spreadet halt.
So.
Gut.
CPU.
Und jetzt war es, wo ich wirklich Bock drauf habe, ist auch schon das letzte Teil.
Danach müssen wir gucken, aber vielleicht schalten wir doch mal ein und gucken uns zumindest das RGB an oder so.
Der Bauer hat das trotzdem mal geköpft.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch sein Job irgendwo, ja.
Also er verdient ja Geld damit.
Da würde ich ganz ehrlich, wenn das mein Job wäre, würde ich das auch machen.
So.
Als letztes die Wasserkühlung.
Ist auch wieder ein fettes Ding.
Du baust alles direkt zusammen.
Mein Gehäuse ist noch nicht da.
Gehäuse zusammenbauen machen wir heute nicht.
Ich hab mein Gehäuse noch in der Post, ist noch nicht da.
Und der Kontaktframe für die CPU ist auch noch nicht da.
Warum köpft man eine CPU?
Weil, wie ich gerade gesagt hab, früher.
Also früher war.
Bis zum 8700K glaube ich, danach gab es das auch nicht mehr.
Das hier oben bei der CPU.
Also hier unten kommt die CPU aufs Mainboard.
Das hier oben nennt man Heatspreader.
Da drunter ist quasi direkt die CPU-Oberseite.
So.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie ist dieser Heatspreader, also diese Metallkappe.
Wie ist die mit der CPU-Oberseite verbunden?
Und beim 8700K war es so.
Zwischen dem Heatspreader, also das was ihr hier oben seht, und der CPU innen drinnen.
War Wärmeleitpaste.
Und das war minderwertige Rotzwärmeleitpaste.
Und was man dann gemacht hat ist, man hat den geköpft, weil geköpft bedeutet.
Man hatte den Kleber entfernt unter dem Heatspreader.
Und hat den Heatspreader abgemacht.
Und hat dann auf die CPU innen drinnen.
So eine Flüssigmetallegierung draufgeschmiert mit einem Wattestäbchen.
Und dann hat man den Heatspreader wieder oben draufgemacht.
Oder manche besonders tapfere und waghalsige Leute haben dann auch direkt den Kühler auf die CPU gemacht.
Wobei da muss man aufpassen, dass man es nicht verkantet, sonst geht es kaputt.
Ja.
Deswegen hat man das geköpft.
Und mit dem Flüssigmetall ist meine CPU glaube ich irgendwie 9 Grad oder so kühler.
Oder noch mehr.
Das hat sich richtig gelohnt.
Die alte.
Also die hier nicht.
Die hier versucht die auch nicht zu köpfen, weil die sind verlötet.
Ja nur weil der Bauer das macht.
Heißt nicht, dass ihr das auch machen solltet.
So und jetzt die Wasserkühlung.
Da bin ich ja wirklich gespannt drauf.
Und zwar als Wasserkühlung.
Ist auch ein mega fettes Ding, Alter.
Ist fast so groß wie der Karton der Grafikkarte.
Haben wir das hier.
Jetzt mal kurz weg.
Hinten hin schmeißen.
So.
Hier haben wir.
Einen Liquid Freezer.
420.
All in one.
CPU Water Cooler.
Das sind.
420 sind dreimal 140 Millimeter Lüfter.
Und es ist die ARGB Version.
Der Unterschied zwischen RGB und ARGB ist.
Dass die ARGB.
Die hat quasi ansteuerbare, also attressible.
Ich glaube das steht für attressible.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Also ansteuerbare LEDs, dass man eben auch verschiedene Farben machen kann.
Und man steuert die, soweit ich das gesehen habe, über das Mainboard.
Also das kommt dann quasi über einen Stecker ans Mainboard.
Und dann kann man es mit der RGB Software einstellen.
Ja.
Upgrade Kit Included.
Ganz wichtig.
Habe ich extra bei der Bestellung dabei geschrieben.
So nach dem Motto, ich baue dann 13900K ein.
Please.
Please mach doch mal das Kit dabei.
Aber anscheinend müssen sie das nicht, weil das Kit ist schon dabei.
So.
Machen wir mal auf.
Oh, ich habe es eingerissen.
Natürlich gleich wieder der letzte Loop hier.
Der letzte Unboxen.
Der letzte Unboxing Loop.
Ähm.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man das aufmacht, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ah, hier oben.
Das könnt ihr gar nicht sehen.
Ah, hier oben macht man das auf.
Okay.
Achtung.
Moment.
Anders drum, anders drum.
Ja, hier ist nicht so viel Platz.
Das ist ein äußerst...
Kacke Häuse, Alter.
Da kommste kaum...
Moment.
Leute, ich leg das jetzt mal kurz auf meinen Stuhl.
Pack das aus.
Und dann...
Nee, ich mach's auf der Erde auf.
Und dann zeige ich euch das Ding.
Hat ja keinen Sinn.
So.
Hier.
Hier sind die Teile.
Andere pfeffer ich mal in die Ecke.
Und jetzt packen wir mal aus.
Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du.
So.
Da ist er.
Guck dir mal da.
Sieht fast aus wie eine zweite Grafikkarte.
So ein bisschen.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie nochmal eine RTX 4090.
Oder?
Müßte zugeben, hatte gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
Stimmt es, dass Elon Musk Twitter wieder verkauft?
Keine Ahnung.
Nach all dem Tammtamm wäre es aber irgendwie komisch, oder?
Okay.
So, also hier kommt dann anscheinend...
Ja, genau.
Hier kommt die Pumpe.
Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung von Wasserkühler.
Aber ich versuche euch das trotzdem mal zu erklären.
Weil so ein paar Sachen habe ich die letzten Jahre über aufgeschnappt.
Ihr könnt mir ja gleich mal sagen.
Für alle, die ein bisschen Ahnung haben, ob das stimmt, was ich erzähle.
Also.
Soweit ich weiß, ist das hier unten, was wir gerade auspacken, ist die Pumpe.
Nicht das da.
Nicht das da ist die Pumpe.
Also, ich packe es mal kurz aus.
Ich packe es mal kurz aus.
Exzellent.
So.
Kette Lüfter.
Exzellent.
So, also.
Soweit ich weiß, ist es folgendermaßen.
Also, hier unten kommt...
Da unten kommt die CPU drauf.
Also, an der Stelle.
Ich habe schon gerade gedacht, das Kabel wäre kaputt.
Aber nein, das Kabel ist nicht kaputt.
Aber das Kabel ist ziemlich, ziemlich geknickt.
Das hätten sie da nicht richtig aufgepasst.
Na gut.
Also, hier kommt die CPU drauf.
Warning.
Please.
Das da abmachen.
Ja gut, ist klar.
Also, soweit ich weiß, ist das folgendermaßen.
Das hier ist die Pumpe.
Die kommt auf die CPU.
Hier ist auch ein kleiner Luft da drin für die Spannungswandler und sowas.
Und hier ist quasi voll, ja, integriert all in one.
Ist hier schon überall flüssig.
Flüssig.
Flüssigkeit drinne.
Also, es ist wahrscheinlich destilliertes Wasser oder irgendwas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was genau in der Wasserkühlung drinne ist.
Muss nicht zwangsläufig Wasser sein.
Schon gar kein Trinkwasser.
Und...
Tja, im Prinzip funktioniert das folgendermaßen.
Ja, guckt mal.
Hier sind Kühlrippen.
Also, hier drinne ist quasi Flüssigkeit drinne.
Das ist die Pumpe.
Und im Endeffekt, das einzige, was passiert, ist, dass Wasser relativ schnell hier durchgepumpt wird.
Oder wahrscheinlich hier reingesaugt, also hier reingesaugt wird.
Daraus gepumpt wird.
Dann wird das durch die Kühlrippen geleitet.
Und über diese Kühlrippen pusten die Lüfter drauf.
Also, im Prinzip, das Wasser fließt da rein.
Das Wasser fließt da warm rein.
Läuft halt durch die Kühlrippen durch.
Und auf der anderen Seite wieder raus.
Also, hier kommt es warm rein, läuft durch und dann ist es am Ende wieder kallen und läuft zur CPU.
Das war es im Endeffekt schon.
Also, das ist das Geheimnis der Wasserkühlung.
Benutzt habe ich selbst noch gar nicht.
Witzigerweise weiß ich jetzt auch gar nicht, für was die Kabel hier alles sind.
Ich vermute mal, dass das hier RGB-Steuerung auf dem Mainboard ist, diese drei PIN.
Und das hier wahrscheinlich Lüftersteuerung.
Also, das dürfte wahrscheinlich so, ja, diese vier PIN, ist das PWM?
Diese vier PIN Lüftersteuerung sein.
Und das hier halt für die RGBs auf dem Mainboard.
Ja.
So sieht es aus.
Chat, das waren die Teile für mein neuen PC.
Der ganze Spaß hat mich jetzt knapp 5000 Euro gekostet.
Also, 4400 irgendwas.
Ihr könnt in die Liste reingucken.
Habe ich eigentlich die Festplatte in die Liste reingeschrieben bei Geizhals?
Was ist das kleine Rad neben dem Schlauch?
Das da?
Das ist ein kleiner Lüfter für die Spannungswandler auf dem Mainboard.
Spannungswandler auf dem Mainboard, ja.
Ich freue mich auch, das zusammenzubauen, Gamer Alex.
Da habe ich richtig Bock drauf.
Vor allem sind das halt absolut Premium-Components.
Und ich habe richtig Bock auf einen neuen Rechner.
Ich hoffe nur, dass jetzt endlich mal das Gehäuse unter Kontakt-Frame kommt.
Und ich hoffe nur, dass jetzt endlich mal das Gehäuse unter Kontakt-Frame kommt.
Nee, der soll wohl relativ leise sein.
Ich bin gespannt.
Also das Schöne ist, dadurch, dass du die Lüfte halt über das Mainboard auch steuern kannst,
ist das im Desktop-Betrieb auch leise.
Was der Vorteil einer Wasserkühlung ist, sie kühlt besser.
Aber für die meisten Anwendungsfälle macht es keinen Unterschied.
So, hier haben wir übrigens noch was dabei.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, hier sind Schrauben und sowas dabei.
Ich muss das mal kurz auf die Erde stellen.
Kurz auf die Erde stellen.
So.
Ich denke mal, hier sind wahrscheinlich Schrauben und so Zeug dabei.
Ja.
Ach hier, nee, das ist das Montage-Kit, guckt mal.
Das ist das Montage-Kit für die CPU.
Das hier muss aufs Mainboard irgendwie, das muss ich mir noch mal genauer angucken.
Also wahrscheinlich muss man...
Ach nee, guckt mal.
Hier.
Das ist das, das brauche ich.
Das ist das, ähm, Upgrade-Kit für den aktuellen Sockel.
Das brauche ich, ja.
Ja, das muss man wahrscheinlich hinten aufs Mainboard machen.
Und dann verschrauben.
Ja, ein bisschen Wärmeleitpaste dabei.
Wärmeleitpaste.
Und der Rest, würde ich sagen, sind wahrscheinlich Ersatzteile und...
Ach hier, nee, das ist für AMD.
Irgendwelche Abstandshalter oder sowas.
Ja, nice, passt schon.
Äh, Wärmeleitpaste werde ich übrigens auch die hier verwenden.
Alternativ habe ich noch, ähm, übrig vom Bauer die, diese...
Wie heißt die vom Bauer?
Kyronaut, Kyronaut oder sowas.
Habe ich noch eine halbe Spritze.
Cryonaut.
Ja.
Aber ich werde die hier verwenden, das macht...
Eigentlich kein Unterschied, welche Wärmeleitpaste.
Ja.
Easy Leute, so schnell...
Kann man...
5K ausgeben aktuell.
Easy Money, easy life.
Aber um das Ganze etwas zu schmälern...
Ich habe Inflationsausgleich von der Arbeit bekommen dieses Jahr.
Und ich habe doppelt das Gehalt bekommen im Dezember.
Also sprich, ich habe ungefähr...
Jetzt auf einen Schlag...
Jetzt mal überlegen, was wird es denn sein?
Drei...
Ja, also irgendwie 8000 Euro oder sowas gekriegt.
Das heißt der Rechner ist auf jeden Fall mit dem Dezembergehalt schon bezahlt.
Das war es aber noch nicht, es geht demnächst weiter.
Ich brauche noch ein neues Handy.
Ich brauche eine neue Capture Card.
Und...
Ich brauche theoretisch auch einen neuen Monitor.
Aktuell habe ich ein BenQ 240 Hertz Monitor.
1080p.
Das ist natürlich für das System der Witz, ja.
Ich will mir einen neuen OLED Monitor kaufen.
Am liebsten ein 1440p 240 Hertz OLED.
Oder, wie spricht man das eigentlich aus?
Ich sage immer OLED, aber was heißt das Wort OLED?
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Oder sagt man OLED.
27 Zoll.
Aber da warte ich noch ein bisschen ab, weil da sind ganz viele Monitore gerade in der Pipeline.
Da will ich mal abwarten.
LG hat jetzt den ersten.
Aber das muss ja nicht sein.
Ich habe jetzt noch ein paar.
Der Monitor wird dann wahrscheinlich wieder um 800 bis 1200 Euro kosten.
Es ist auf jeden Fall teuer.
Und wie gesagt, vor vier Monaten habe ich noch ein neues Auto geholt.
Dieses Jahr war ich echt nicht sparsam.
Aber ihr kennt mich.
Ich gebe normalerweise nie Geld aus.
Dieses Jahr war die Ausnahme, was das angeht.
Ich glaube, so viel Geld wie dieses Jahr habe ich noch nie im Leben ausgegeben.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben ausgegeben.
Es ist tatsächlich zum ersten Mal weniger auf dem Konto geworden.
Und eine ordentliche Kamera.
Korrekt, dass ich diesen Mist hier nicht mit dem iPhone mehr filmen muss.
Handy, wahrscheinlich ein iPhone, ein iPhone 14 Pro.
Aber kein Max, weil mir zu groß.
Aktuell habe ich ja auch hier einen iPhone 14 Pro.
Aktuell habe ich ja auch hier ein iPhone.
Aber das ist ein Firmen Handy.
Und wenn ich da kündige Ende des Jahres, kann ich das ja schlecht behalten.
Genau, das denke ich mir auch ohne Mist, Leute.
Mein aktueller Rechner, also der 8700K, den ich aktuell habe,
der hat jetzt ziemlich genau, sogar ein bisschen länger.
Der hat über fünf Jahre gehalten.
Fünf Jahre, einen Monat oder so.
Oder fünf Jahre, zwei Monate.
Also der hat über fünf Jahre gehalten.
Der hier hält wahrscheinlich wieder fünf Jahre.
Und selbst wenn nicht, juckt mich das auch nicht.
Ich wäre sogar froh darüber, wenn es nicht so lange hält.
Wisst ihr warum? Klingt jetzt erstmal blöd.
Aber wisst ihr, ich wäre eigentlich froh, wenn er nicht so lange hält,
weil das bedeuten würde, dass Grafik und Spiele
wieder größere Fortschrittssprünge machen.
Was aber nicht passieren wird, deswegen gehe ich ganz stark davon aus,
der wird locker wieder fünf Jahre halten.
Was mit dem Alten passiert, der wird zum Vorschau-Rechner für den Stream.
Also ich habe da einen Rechner stehen und da einen Rechner.
Also von eurer Seite aus.
Da steht mein Rechner, also hier so auf der Seite,
steht der Rechner, wo ich spiele drauf bzw. jetzt hier auch streame.
Und hier steht der Vorschau-Rechner für Streaming.
Da wo ich den Chat und so drauf habe.
Wo ich auch nebenbei ein paar Sachen drauflaufen habe,
sind zwei komplett getrennte Systeme und das werde ich ausmalen.
Also den, den ich jetzt als Vorschau-Rechner verwende, kommt weg.
Und der, den ich jetzt zum Stream verwende,
kommt als Vorschau-Rechner hin, wenn er neu hinkommt.
Plistering Speed Endless Victory.
Lul. Ja, was machen wir jetzt noch?
Eigentlich nichts großartig, oder? Was soll man noch großartig machen?
Ich habe hier keinen Platz, um da irgendwie groß was zusammenzustöpseln.
Zumal ich mir das eh alles mal in Ruhe angucken muss.
Ich mein, das Netzteil haben wir vergessen, Leute.
Wir haben das Netzteil vergessen.
Sagt doch einer was, Netzteil fehlt noch.
Was ich für die Festplatte bezahlt habe?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Die habe ich nämlich noch gehabt.
Die hatte ich mir vor einer ganzen Weile gekauft.
Die war in meinem Nass vorher drinne.
Ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Guck einfach mal auf Geizhals.
Also was wir machen können, ist,
wir könnten das theoretisch mal zusammenstecken.
Aber wir können es halt nicht ins Gehäuse einbauen,
weil ich habe das Gehäuse noch nicht da.
Zeig noch mal kurz das Mainboard. Kann ich dir zeigen?
Wenn ich es finde, unter dem ganzen Haufen hier,
Sekunde, hier ist das Mainboard.
Hier ist das Mainboard.
Mainboard.
So, Mainboard.
Was willst du wissen?
Also, das ist ein Gigabyte Mainboard.
Ich weiß, sagen viele, macht Probleme.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn es wirklich Probleme macht,
schicke ich das zurück und hole ein anderes.
Nein, den Kontaktframe, der sollte heute eigentlich kommen,
kam heute aber nicht.
Und das ist auch die Sache,
der Grund, warum ich jetzt nicht wirklich zusammenstecken will
und anschalten will.
Weil ich muss es jetzt umbauen und alles, ja.
Ja, das ist das Mainboard.
Hier kannst du deine System-SSD hinmachen.
RAM, USB, Stromversorgung, Stromversorgung.
Noch mehr USB.
System, also hier kann man, steht auch extra da.
Hier ist der Anschluss für die Wasserkühlung.
Hier ist noch mal Anschluss für extra Lüfter,
falls man noch extra welche hat.
Hier oben kommt der CPU-Lüfter dran, falls man einen hat.
Haben wir ja nicht.
Und hier kann man LED.
Also das Ding hat quasi viermal LED-Zeug zum Anschließen.
Sollte ja irgendwo reichen, ne?
Ich meine, ich brauche die zwei.
Nee, ach nee, das sind nur zwei LED-Anschlüsse, guck mal.
Ich brauche die auch beide.
Ich brauche den hier für die Wasserkühlung
und den hier für die Grafikkarte.
Ansonsten mehr RGB habe ich ja nicht.
Also RAM ist RGB, aber den kannst du so nicht steuern
über einen extra Kabel.
Ja, so sieht das Mainboard aus.
Stromanschluss für die Wasserkühlung.
Ähm, der geht nicht übers Mainboard, oder?
Der kriegt, der kommt extra dran,
vom Netzteil, würde ich mal sagen.
Ah, das ist ein Molex-Stecker.
Ja, lasst mal kurz gucken.
Okay, wo, wie schließt man das?
Eine gute Frage, Chat.
Ich mache mal kurz das Mainboard.
Wie schließt man die Wasserkühlung an?
Lasst mal kurz gucken.
Sekunde.
Wie schließt man die Wasserkühlung an?
Also, wo ist der Stromanschluss für die Wasserkühlung?
Eine gute Frage.
Ah, nee.
Hä?
Kekkel.
Sata-Strom?
Also, an die Pumpe kommt doch nicht der Strom, oder?
Oder kommt der Strom an die Pumpe?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo man das anschließt.
PWM 12 Volt?
Meint ihr, das reicht?
Das ist der einzige Stecker, den man braucht für das ganze Ding?
Wirklich?
Das ist alles?
Okay, nice.
Naja, gut.
Was heißt, das ist alles?
Ich meine, warum auch nicht?
Das sind Lüfter und das ist die Pumpe.
Das kannst du doch alles hier mit 12 Volt drüber treiben.
Ja, okay, leuchtet ein.
Ja, nee, passt.
Leuchtet ein.
Jaja, easy, easy eigentlich.
Easy as fuck.
So, wir packen jetzt auch das Netzteil aus.
Hab ich jetzt ganz vergessen.
Pog Netzteil.
Dazu müssen wir erstmal ein bisschen Platz machen.
Wobei, ich glaube, das Netzteil kriegen wir so ausgepackt.
Also, Netz...
Boah, ist das schwer, alter Mann.
Netzteil ist ein Dark Power 12.
Be quiet.
Machen wir mal auf.
Wenn ich mich jetzt aus Versehen mit dem Messer schneide, Leute, ist das an Selbstverletzungen?
Ich werde gebannt?
Man war ja keine Absicht.
Arbeitsunfall, ja, melde ich gleich der Berufsgenossenschaft.
Wobei, ich bin IHK Mitglied.
Vielleicht kann ich jetzt den melden.
Okay, also Netzteil, auf geht's.
Schauen wir mal rein.
Ah, erste Mal, erste Mal aufmachen.
Ein sealed Sticker.
Oh Mann, das geht mir dann richtig auf.
Sekunde.
Ich muss das mal kurz abpulen.
Okay, ist offen.
Poggers.
Hast du Katzen?
Ja, eine.
Be quiet, Dark Power 12.
No compromise, silence and performance.
Alles klar.
Silence.
Da ist es.
Alter, wie viel Verpackungsmüll.
Da haben wir hier die ganzen Kabel.
Hier ist das Netzteil.
Da haben wir wieder irgendwas für Wasser im Gehäuse.
Wasser oder irgendwie Luftfeuchtigkeit oder so, weg damit.
Und raus ist es.
Da ist das Netzteil.
Hey.
Poggen.
Netzteil.
So, und dann haben wir hier noch die Packung mit den Kabeln.
Gucken wir uns gleich mal an, was da alles drin ist.
Dark Power.
Okay.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Wir haben ein Netzteil, ein...
Ups.
Falsch rum.
Ein modulares Netzteil, selbstverständlich.
Chat, mal eine Frage an euch.
Wann hattet ihr das letzte Mal ein Netzteil, was nicht modular war?
Also, wo hier noch so ein Riesenwulst an Kabel hinten hing.
Ich glaube, die auch nur etwas besseren Netzteile gibt es doch heute gar nicht mehr unmodular, oder?
Gestern im Retro-Rechner.
Ja, okay.
Was hier unten das ist, weiß ich nicht.
OCK.
Netzteil übertakken.
Kein Schimmer.
Hinten ganz normaler Kaltgerätestecker.
So, und in der Box sind halt die Kabel fürs modulare Netzteil drin.
Ja, wir haben dann solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel...
SATA-Stromstecker.
Auf der Seite kommt es dann ins Netzteil.
Tja, hier.
Hier kommt es ins Netzteil.
Auf der anderen Seite hast du SATA-Stromstecker.
Olle Molex-Anschluss.
Kaltgerätestecker ist mit dabei.
Ah, hier wieder ein paar Kabelbinder und so Velcro-Dinger.
Dann haben wir noch mehr SATA- und klassische Molex-Stecker.
Wait a minute.
Was ist das?
Ups.
Jetzt habe ich den Lüfter oder so verloren.
Was ist das?
Dark Power?
Overclocking?
Das ist ein Netzteil.
Das soll nicht übertaktet werden.
Was ist das?
Hä?
Okay, das verstehe ich nicht, was man damit...
Also den Sinn davon verstehe ich nicht.
Hat irgendjemand einen Plan, wofür das ist?
Wassergebend 8 Hobbits.
Na, hast du das Video von Algorithmen verstehen geguckt?
Alles Highend.
Ja.
Und soll ich euch nochmal was Highendiges zeigen?
Einen guten PB Swiss Ratschenschraubendreher mit Bithalter im Deckel.
Nicht Linus Tech Tips.
Nein, meiner ist besser als Linus Tech Tips, aber auch teurer.
Also, wofür der Overclocker ist, ist mit Overclock-Schalter leuchtet mir nicht ein.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Wir haben SATA.
Ne, nicht SATA.
4-Pin, 8-Pin, ATX-Stecker, die alten Stecker für Grafikkarten, als die noch nicht so viel
gebraucht haben und den ATX-Main-Connector.
Ja, nice.
Alles, was man braucht am Start.
Hogu und zu ist es.
Bauforum24 hat den auch empfohlen.
Okay, nice.
Die gucke ich ab und zu mal.
Vielleicht habe ich es ja sogar da damals aufgeschnappt, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, Leute, so sieht es aus.
Ich überlege gerade, ob es irgendwie Sinn macht, da was anzuschließen jetzt.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, nee, macht es nicht, weil der Kontakt-Frame ist nicht da.
Ich will die CPU nicht reinmachen.
Wärmeleit passt da drauf, alles dran.
Und dann morgen schon wieder ab, wenn der Kontakt-Frame da ist, macht eigentlich keinen
Sinn.
RAM und M2 kann rein.
Würde euch das freuen, Leute, wenn ich die M2 und den RAM einbaue.
Brauchen tun wir, also sinnvoll ist es nicht wirklich.
Ich war ein kompletten Stream, ja.
Ich war ein kompletten, ich war ein kompletten Stream, wo wir das zusammenbauen.
Umfrage.
Ich war ein kompletten Stream, wo ich das zusammenbaue.
Komm, da hat doch keiner was von, wenn ich da jetzt die SSD reinstecke und den RAM reinstecke.
Das habt ihr doch alle selbst schon mal gemacht.
Ey, wir machen keine Umfrage.
Wir machen einen Stream, wo ich das Ding zusammenbaue und das geht erst, wenn das Gehäuse da
ist.
Chat, wir machen keine Umfrage.
Wenn das Gehäuse da ist und der Kontakt-Frame da ist, dann bauen wir das zusammen um.
Wir müssen uns allerdings angucken, wie man den Kontakt-Frame installiert.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das müssen wir uns tatsächlich jetzt mal anschauen.
Zeig mal her.
Da hat der Bauer doch bestimmt ein Video zu.
Haben wir uns das nicht letztens angeguckt?
Das haben wir uns doch das letzte Mal angeguckt.
Das war doch total easy, oder?
Außerdem ist das Ding noch gar nicht da.
Ja, Chat, so sieht es aus.
Neue Rechner am Start.
Mein halbes Zimmer hier, mein halbes Arbeitszimmer ist voll mit Verpackung gerade.
Werde ich jetzt alles mal aufeinander stellen.
Ich lasse die Sachen ausgepackt.
Hebe mir aber die Verpackung auf.
Kann ich das nämlich mal zeigen, getrennt.
Ich werde da noch ein Video machen.
Dazu, wenn das Gehäuse da ist und wenn der Kontakt-Frame da ist.
Und natürlich abschließend, wenn es zusammengebaut ist und das ganze läuft.
Yep.
Bist du ordnungsgemäß geerdet?
Na selbstverständlich.
Ich habe sogar eine Anti-Starting-Matte unten drunter.
Da kann ja gar nichts passieren.
Nein, Gehäuse ist was anderes.
Gehäuse ist ein Meshify 2XL.
Das da.
Die Wasserkühlung machst du oben rein.
Korrekt.
Die Wasserkühlung mache ich oben rein.
Was auch jegliche Luft an der falschen Stelle Probleme vorbeugen sollte.
Hier oben kommt die Wasserkühlung rein.
Die Lüfter lasse ich standardmäßig so drinnen.
Gleich brauche ich unten noch zwei Lüfter, die noch zusätzlich reinpusten.
Mal schauen.
Mal gucken.
Ja.
Nicht rein?
Doch rein.
Immer gut, wenn man ein bisschen Überdruck im Gehäuse hat.
Und nachdem ich ja quasi zwei Lüfter habe, die reinpusten, ein Lüfter, der hinten rauszieht.
Oben drei Lüfter, die rausziehen.
Und den Netzteil unten, der im Prinzip auch rauszieht.
Sollte ich vielleicht noch welche einbauen, die reinpusten.
Ja, mal gucken, was ich mir hole.
Ich werde es erstmal begutachten, ob das überhaupt notwendig ist.
Weil ansonsten hast du eh ganz guten Airflow mit dem Gehäuse.
Das Gehäuse ist halt auch wieder riesengroß.
Aber ich meine, ihr habt die Grafikkarte gesehen.
Intake ist nur vorne aktuell, ja.
Also ihr habt aber gesehen, wie fett die Grafikkarte ist, wie fett die Wasserkühlung ist.
Und wie fett das alles insgesamt ist, nicht nur der Preis.
Da brauche ich ein fettes Gehäuse, dass das alles sicher reinpasst.
Ich hoffe, das kommt morgen oder spätestens übermorgen.
Ich will das jetzt, ich will das endlich bilden.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Chat, was machen wir jetzt noch?
Machen wir überhaupt noch was?
Wir haben ausgepackt.
Videos.
Oder Bettge.
Ich muss jetzt eigentlich noch aufräumen.
Ich muss jetzt noch aufräumen, ich muss das ganze Zeug wieder zusammenpacken und so.
Kannst du kurz ohne Kühler einschalten, nur um zu schauen, ob es postet?
Nee, kann ich nicht, da müsste ich die CPU ja drauf machen.
Und ich will die CPU erst drauf machen, wenn ich den richtigen Kontaktframe dran habe und alles.
Nee.
Nee, Leute, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, heute machen wir nichts Großartiges mehr.
Als nächstes mal zusammenbaustrieben.
Ja, jetzt ist auch noch nicht Bettge.
Ich muss den Kram jetzt erst mal zusammenräumen wieder.
Zusammenräumen.
Nun gut, gibt es irgendjemanden, den wir hosten können?
Hast du im Discord was geschrieben?
Okay.
Zeit mal kurz, gibt es irgendwelche kleinen Leute, die ich oft gucke, die da sind?
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns dann.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
Bis dann, tschüss.